[Music]
foreign
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream
187. why are we so slow today
186 186 yes oh okay 186. um all right
yes it is the 186th live stream I'm Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather on
super speed okay all right I'm
apparently the uh the dial which adjusts
my speed has been set on the setting in
which it makes large jumps rather than
small jumps we're going to dial this in
over the next few minutes there we go
too much about it all right um but uh
anyway it is 186 it is 180. I believe
unless I've got that wrong it's 186
machines let's not linger on that
question right you're Dr Brett Weinstein
I'm Dr Heather Hein here we are with uh
a live stream evolutionary lens of the
Dark Horse podcast we've been coming at
you with this for a good long time now
yes over three years it has been over
three years and we're just we're just
gonna keep on going so um you can join
our watch party at locals right now or
you can uh join in what would be a chat
elsewhere
um but that is that is the the place the
only place that the chat is happening
and uh we encourage you to join our
locals for both that reason and because
the private q a that we've been doing um
at my patreon for almost three years or
actually over three years now we're
going to be moving to our locals as of
this month so that'll be on the last
Sunday of the month and uh and we very
much encourage you to go there and
you'll also be able uh to get to our
Discord server there from our locals
um
so we're going to talk about all the
other places you can find us and and
such at the end
um but uh for now uh we'll also do a q a
live q a after this episode and
um the one remaining piece of business
that we want to talk about before we
launch into content is of course our
sponsors for whom we are very grateful
whom we uh take seriously and and vet
carefully and we have three as always at
the top of the hour we literally make
this all possible they make this all
possible yes we are extremely grateful
for uh all of all three of them this
week they are uncruise American Heart
for gold and mud water
our first sponsored this week being
uncruise small ship Adventures on cruise
explores by sea and by land they have
boats that hold orders of magnitude
fewer people than most cruise boats and
they take their passengers to some of
the world's most magnificent places
Panama and Costa Rica Galapagos the Sea
of Cortez in Mexico Alaska even our own
backyard the San Juan Islands when
unku's first approached us we were
skeptical our standards for travel and
especially anything bordering on
adventure travel are very high we have
years of experience leading trips to the
scavalines of Eastern Washington and the
Columbia River Gorge as well as the
Andean paramo Galapagos and the Amazon
we know that most trips do not meet
expectations uncruise in contrast
exceeds expectations the small boats of
uncrews allow passengers to get real
deep experience the largest boat can
accommodate a mere 86 guests the boats
of uncruise take small groups of people
to places that larger boats can't go and
the excursions are designed to bring
people into deep nature without
destroying it when we spoke to CEO Dan
Blanchard we discovered a shared ethos
with him the value of wild roadless
nature the value of exploration and of
observation
we took it on cruise week-long trip to
the Inland Waters of Southeast Alaska in
early May of this year and were blown
away by what we saw and what we were
able to do we saw sea otters with their
pups mountain goats Eagles in their
nests brown and black bears puffins
orcas humpbacks Arctic turns to be fair
only Brett's other puffins but uh on the
entire boat I may be the only person but
you got a beautiful picture oh man yeah
um Arctic turns too many species to list
really and my left I don't know how
everyone was on one side of the boat
looking at a bunch of awesome stuff when
you wandered to the other side of the
boat and there they were puffins part of
my nature yeah well sometimes that's me
but it wasn't this time I really wanted
puffins anyway there were puffins there
we just didn't all see them
um and mile after mile of the most
breathtaking scenery each day we got off
the boat to hike or kayak and the crew
and naturalist guides were to a person
kind knowledgeable and enthusiastic the
food was surprisingly good as well and
food preferences and sensitivities were
handled handled perfectly
and every sailing with uncruises
all-inclusive Transportation drinks Farm
to Table Cuisine daily excursions
everything is included uncrews
understands that the boat is just a tool
there's small ship cruises take guests
through communities and locales in the
ground so they can have actual
experiences on Cruz is giving Dark Horse
listeners a fantastic deal 500 off their
current cruises an offer that you can
combine with any other savings that you
might find or have so start planning
your next trip with trip troop trip next
I'm gonna I'm Gonna Fill that in with
the appropriate vowel so start planning
your next trip with on cruise today and
take advantage of your great offer our
great offer go now to uncrews.com Pages
slash Darkhorse remember to save 500 on
your trip go now to uncrews.com Pages
slash Darkhorse
and again that's uncrews.com Pages slash
Darkhorse and uh I feel like my
um Tempo dial is now um inching up so oh
you're just yeah just let that bring it
down we're going to bring it down a
little bit folks um yeah I find myself
thinking back to that cruise regularly I
have been all summer which is a very
good sign about the quality of it it
wasn't just great while we were there
but it gave us lots to think about
absolutely
our second sponsor this week is American
Hartford gold if you listen to Dark
Horse regularly then you already know
just how incompetent and unstable many
of our institutions are becoming you may
well have known that before you were
listening to Dark Horse interest rates
are Sky High we are caught between
runaway inflation and a recession we are
assured that all is fine while the cost
of food housing Medical Care schools
everything climbs our leaders are
increasingly nonsensical all of this
threatens businesses jobs and retirement
funds finding ways to secure your nest
egg and insulate your wealth is thus
more important than ever and adding
precious metals to your assets is a
great way to stabilize your Investments
and protect yourself financially
American Hartford gold is a precious
metals dealer that can help you do just
that American Hartford gold helps
individuals and families protect their
wealth by diversifying with precious
metals they make it simple and easy to
protect your savings and retirement
accounts with physical gold and silver
with one short phone call they can have
physical gold and silver delivered
delivered right to your door
or you can get gold or silver inside
your IRA or 401K they are the highest
rate firm in the country with an A plus
rating from the Better Business Bureau
and thousands of satisfied clients and
if you call them right now they will
give you up to five thousand dollars of
free silver on your first qualifying
order contact them today by visiting the
link in the episode description below or
call
866-828-1117 that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to
998899 again to get American Hartford
Hartford Golds Dark Horse offer call
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse 2998899
cover your assets
can Hartford gold all right our final
sponsor this week is mud water that's
mud wtr mud water which makes truly
delicious products mud water makes a
fantastic drink it's spicy and delicious
and chock full of adaptogenic mushrooms
and ayurvedic herbs I'm going to ask you
later to help me understand what
ayurvedic herbs are but for the moment
I'll just say that with 1 7th of
caffeine as a cup of coffee you get
energy without anxiety Jitters or the
crash of coffee and without it radically
altering your pace of speech if you like
the routine of making and drinking a cup
of warmth in the morning but don't drink
coffee or trying to cut down try mud
water
if you're looking for a different way to
kick off your day with a delicious
warming enhancing cup of something that
isn't just a caffeine Rush try mud water
each ingredient was added with intention
it has cacao and chai for just a hint of
caffeine lion's mane mushrooms to
support Focus cordyceps to help support
physical performance chaga and Rishi to
support your immune system and cinnamon
which is a potent antioxidant also quite
delicious I'm not a fungus and not a
fungus that is quite true it's a bark
which is worse than its bite mud water
also makes a non-dairy creamer out of
coconut milk and MCT and a sweetener out
of coconut palm sugars and lucuma the
fruit of an Andean tree used by the Inca
to add if you prefer those options or
you can mix and match add a bit of their
coconut milk and MCT creamer with some
honey from bees real bees or use mud
Waters lucuma and coconut palm sugar
sweetener and skip the bees entirely mud
water is a hundred percent USDA organic
non-GMO gluten-free vegan and kosher
certified the rabbis have told us mud
Waters flavor is warm and spicy with a
hint of chocolate plus Masala chai which
includes Ginger and cardamom nutmeg and
cloves it's also a delicious blending
into its also delicious blending it into
a smoothie try it with banana and Ice
milk or milk-like substances mint a
touch of honey and cacao and nibs
to get 15 percent off go to mudwater.com
that's
m-u-d-w-t-r.com slash Dark Horse pod to
support the show use the code Dark Horse
pod for 15 off
[Music]
oh yeah no we're podcasting oh we're
back oh sorry
um
I was just reading my issue of County
Highway that came this week County
Highway the first issue has taken this
is awesome this piece I was reading son
of Joshua Tree I was actually just
looking back at the lead because I
finished this uh yesterday son of Joshua
Tree Coachella babies overrun Desert
Paradise Airbnb schemers displaced
weirdos and freaks mysterious energies
remain it's like four different sets of
uh headlines for those of you unaware
um County highway is uh a new
publication uh the um the brainchild of
a number of people
um including but not limited to David
Samuels and Walter Kern uh they have at
the top America's only newspaper which
is obviously a bit tongue-in-cheek but
they are responding to
um the need for good honest and uh
enjoyable both journalism and uh and
just stuff that you would find in
newspapers and so here it is this County
highway is not online I mean they have a
website and you can go and subscribe
online and then you will get it to to
your mailbox and they've got in this
issue a piece by RFK Jr on Falcons and
they've got stuff on logging camps and a
number a number of things including
including column by me but that is not
the reason to subscribe you can also
find it across the country in a number
of bookstores feed stores record stores
lots of places that such such
Publications magazines and such might be
sold you will find this and once you
pick up a copy you'll probably want to
subscribe yeah super cool and you know
America's only newspaper where you don't
have to put news in scarecrows that's
right that's right actual news yeah
wheat crop disaster worse since 1917
stress tweet produces only a single
grain it's just fabulous fabulous stuff
here so I recommend this as well not a
paid sponsor at all but but uh friends
of the show and we are enthusiastic
about this amazing and very unique
project indeed
uh all right oh actually before we
before we move on to the serious stuff
of the episode about which you have many
things
I want to consider your observation in
that last ad that cinnamon is a bark now
this reminds me of and I think we've
mentioned this on the on the show before
that we were
gosh 15 years ago probably in an Ikea in
their like seconds room because Ikea
wasn't cheap enough we had to go to
their seconds room
um and there's actually some interesting
stuff to be found uh in Ikea's seconds
room as as it turns out uh including as
it turns out
um a solid wood bench that we still have
in our entry today it was like slightly
barred
um you know just a tiny bit of mooring
but it was
um uh a hundred percent mango wood
because mango is not just a fruit of
course mango is a species of plant that
is happens to have as its growth habit
it's a tree form and of course therefore
you know lots of trees wouldn't make
good Furniture but it turns out that
Mango Wood does and when we were
interested in it but in the second part
of Ikea you it's not really clear it's
not the same sort of thing that you do
to go and check out we had to find
someone who worked at Ikea to get him to
you know get it to us and he objected
mightily to our characterization of a
piece of furniture as being made of
mango mango right yeah he said uh we
don't we don't do that here mango is a
fruit we don't make furniture out of
fruit and he claimed to have tasted the
bench and it didn't taste remotely of
mango no he did not but the rest of the
story is actually true right
um and it was
both surprising and not surprising to
hear from someone who had just never
been in the place where mangoes are
grown that they have internalized what
they occasionally find in their Market
as as if delivered by gods right like
this fruit just comes down from the sky
and shows up in like plastic clam shell
cases right
um and that's all it is there's nothing
else known as mango out there and so
that story reminded me I was reminded of
that when you said that cinnamon was a
bark what at what I said it's not a
fungus because that's sort of a list of
mostly fungus something you get to
cinnamon
the part of cinnamon that is used in mud
water
is the Bark of the cinnamon tree yes
cinnamon isn't a bark so the product
there's a bark cinnamon itself it's a
seed until the very end you caught me
and you caught me I was speaking in in
shorthand and I was doing that while we
are recalibrating the speed at which I
talk in regular hand why I'm talking
with my hands I don't know but you know
it's got an ethnic thing I guess but yep
well I'm glad I'm glad we covered that
topic-ish
yeah just uh it's it's just one of the
sort of the ways that biologists at
least organismal biologists such as
ourselves wander around the world seeing
how people categorize things as the bit
that humans use yeah right and I know
you don't you don't do that you just you
you said it that way in line in an ad
read
I'm following my Interruption so I was
already throwing you right
um but I'm I'm reminded that for the
most part we tend to see the whole
organisms in things uh and it's it makes
for instance shopping at a grocery store
rather a longer process because you're
considering you know what what is what
is this what was the original plant what
you know it does it make sense for
instance uh to be buying
apples
in August
Ina this is going to be pretty old
apples uh there's going to be old apples
or apples from afar remove whereas Stone
fruits and cherries and um and berries
yeah this is the moment this is the
moment so thinking about what the
organism is and where it grows and when
it grows and how it was grown is all
part of the sort of organismal biology
approach to the world it results in lots
of practical advice like if you were to
encounter a cinnamon tree and feel
inclined to eat directly from it stop
when you get past the bark
so
where is cinnamon native I think it's
going to be tropical Asia
I don't actually know I don't know and I
don't think I I feel confident that
we've never seen it I've never seen it
in the wild whereas we have seen you
know we have seen nutmeg trees right and
we have and in in force and not just in
in in
um human produced farms for a nutmeg but
you know we we run into nutmeg and Balsa
and various other things that people
will have heard of but when you're
wandering around near tropical
rainforest you you see these trees if
you know what you're looking for
um I don't think I've ever seen a
cinnamon tree
therefore I don't have any idea what the
fruits look like therefore I don't know
um who tends to
um eat the fruits my guess is going to
be Birds but I don't know and I don't
know if it's if it's bird distributed
it's probably not very good for humans
but it's a possibility yeah if it's even
a fruiting tree which is very likely but
not certain not dead certain
I think it's a I think it's a dicot
which is going to make it fruiting we're
going to know soon enough yeah yeah okay
all right anyway
uh you were hoping to talk about some
things yeah I uh I want to lead us
through a series of uh connections that
proceed from something that we talked
about in fact last week it wasn't the
first time we discussed this but last
week we talked about a clip from uh a
interview that gads that did with Paul
offit and in that clip
Paul Offutt suggested
that the myocarditis and pericarditis
that is observed after mRNA vaccinations
for covid might be the result of the
fact that the spike protein mimics the
chemical
shape effectively of the actin protein
in heart cells and that therefore the
unfortunate choice of the spike protein
might result in the immune system
attacking those proteins doing damage to
the heart which would be truly
unfortunate but what I said was that
this looked like a limited Hangout
because what it did by blaming the spike
protein as the root cause was liberate
us to start loading other proteins onto
the MRNA platform for other diseases or
potentially other proteins even for
covid and so my claim was that he was
missing something that he should know
and in fact choosing to blame the spike
protein because what it did is limits
the the bad press surrounding the
destruction of Hearts by these vaccines
to the choice of antigen which can
easily be fixed the next time it
effectively exonerates the MRNA platform
if true if true if true
yes yeah obviously that's so that's a
hypothesis and what I pointed out was a
hypothesis that you and I have talked
about quite a number of times here on
Dark Horse I went back and with the help
of our Clips guy David found the
original place where I had presented the
hypothesis to begin with and it was
February of 22.
in February of 22 I laid out uh a
hypothesis and hypothesis for the
damage to Hearts remember myocarditis
means inflammation inflammation is a
symptom of heart damage
and we have since seen uh quite a number
of pieces of evidence about things
related to this damage but anyway it's
become a central Focus because it is the
most obvious form of damage that results
from these vaccines and so there's been
a lot of battling back and forth over
what it doesn't doesn't mean
how it compares to covet itself Etc but
the hypothesis for that I first deployed
in February of 22 that we Revisited in
our last live stream and Compares it is
a distinct mechanism from the one Paul
off it lays out suggests that the
vaccines by their very nature will
result in the cells that translate the
mrnas into proteins proteins I don't
know why
proteins no
proteins any cell that translates these
mRNA messages into proteins is going to
be targeted by the immune system which
will incorrectly regard them as virally
infected because they are putting out
the signature of a virally infected cell
being that it has molecules that look
like your own molecules and it has
molecules that look foreign any cell
that gives that signal is suggesting to
the immune system that it is virally
infected and destroying it is while bad
the best thing to do because that cell
if it is virally infected is not going
to become uninfected
the best of a bad situation so far as
the immune system can see right
now a paper emerged this week and I
don't know whether this is just a simple
coincidence or whether off it was trying
to seed the world with the idea that the
problem was the spike protein molecular
structure looking like a heart muscle
proteins or not it could be just a
coincidence or or it could be mere
coincidence or it could be meaningful
maybe he was trying to get ahead of this
paper that was going to emerge in
science Immunology which is a high
profile top-tier journal and so Zach do
you want to uh show the paper
I've got it on my screen too if you want
to show that
okay so here we have the paper
um
it the title is
cytokinopathy with aberrant cytotoxic
lymphocytes and pro-fibric myeloid
response in SARS cov2 mRNA
vaccine-associated myocarditis
and what this paper does is it looks at
the
pathology in people who are experiencing
myocarditis following mRNA vaccination
for covid and it analyzes at the level
of the cellular and molecular
environment in which the myocarditis is
happening it analyzes the various
components in order to test competing
hypotheses about what might be causing
this uh this pathology and so what I'm
proposing to do
is to go through I think we should go
there's a little uh paragraph that has
been inserted that describes the work
and then there is the abstract of the
work which summarizes the work the
authors themselves summarize the work in
the abstract as a standard scientific
process I don't have in the in the
official PDF of the paper I don't have
the uh like lay abstract you lay
abstract but I think we should go
through the real abstract and I will say
um I did take a course in immunobiology
many years ago I speak immunobiology for
this reason but I'm not fluent in it and
I'm not current in it this this is you
know what I learned in immunobiology has
stood the test of time it's high quality
stuff and among the uh best things I did
as an undergraduate was taking this
course it has it has paid back dividends
each and every year since I I learned a
tremendous amount but anyway I'm going
to use what I understand to try to
translate as much of this abstract as
possible and you will see the relevance
to this question
raised by
um offit and his proposal and my
proposal from February of 22 which is
now finally getting some traction
okay the abstract says
and you will help me if I screw it up
because there are a lot of uh complex
technical terms here rare immune
mediated cardiac tissue inflammation can
occur after vaccination including after
SARS cov2 mRNA vaccines now they have to
say rare because you have to count out
of the appropriate Gods on this you
can't possibly be caught in a major
journal like this admitting that the
injuries from these vaccines are
actually shockingly common yeah mostly
abstracts we have seen that have in any
way found damage associated with these
vaccines have ended with a sentence that
is that is something to the effect of
but but despite all of this it is still
necessary that everyone go and get
vaccinated right away right so this this
does not have that but it begins with
rare it has to say that and then
somewhere you hear an echo across the
academy where everyone goes amen right
okay however the underlying immune
cellular and molecular mechanisms
driving is pathology remain poorly
understood
here we investigated a cohort of
patients who developed myocarditis and
or pericarditis and I should say
myocarditis is inflammation of the heart
itself pericarditis is inflammation of
the pericardium which is the sac in
which the heart sits so these are both
heart Associated inflammation but in a
slightly different tissue yeah I mean I
with elevated troponin you've heard us
mention troponin recently in the study
that we covered that John Campbell had
covered where instead of waiting for
people to walk in with some sort of a
pathology that caused them to seek
medical help they simply assessed
troponin levels in people who had been
vaccinated and found them in something
like one in 35 people indicating an
awful lot of damage that's subclinical
that doesn't cause you to seek attention
from a doctor but is enough that it's
measurable in your blood but I'm sure
it'll be fine it'll be just fine of
course uh amen
um B type
uh natural
peptide and C-reactive protein levels as
well as cardiac imaging abnormality
shortly after SARS cov2 mRNA vaccination
so these are just markers that they're
using contrary to early hypotheses
patients did not demonstrate features of
hypersensitivity myocarditis nor did
they have exaggerated SARS cov2 specific
neutralizing antibody responses
consistent with Hyper immune humeral
mechanisms specific or neutralizing
antibody responses so what this is going
to take a little unpacking but what
they're saying is people have suggested
that there might be some folks who I
think this is what they're saying some
folks may have sensitivities which make
them prone to myocarditis and they may
be just simply triggered by this vaccine
they don't see evidence of that they
also say that there's no evidence with
Hyper immune humeral mechanisms now what
they're talking about here humeral
mechanisms are not entirely limited to
but they are primarily talking about
antibodies of the kind that you have
heard overly focused upon with
discussions of these coveted vaccines
what they're saying is we do not see an
overabundance of SARS cov2 antibodies
causing the heart
to to be inflamed okay so they are
ruling out these proposals
We additionally found no evidence of
cardiac targeted antibodies oops Auto
antibodies Auto antibodies this is what
Paul offit was suggesting right that
autoimmune antibodies created because
the spike protein mimicked what he said
was the heavy chain of the actin
molecule and the hearts would result in
those antibodies being findable they
didn't find them instead unbiased
systematic immune serum profiling
revealed elevations in circulating
interleukins of a number of different
kinds chemokines of a number of
different kinds and Matrix
metalloproteases Nutella proteases I
don't I don't know the significance of
those the second two classes of
molecules these are uh enzymes I don't
know I don't know much about it so
they're saying they didn't find them
subsequent deep immune profiling using
single cell RNA repertoire sequencing of
peripheral blood mononuclear cells
during acute disease revealed expansion
of activated cxcr3
cytotoxic T cells and NK cells now this
is where the rubber meets the road and I
realized that was not a sentence to make
you think anything important had
happened but what they're saying well no
I mean many people would read that
sentence and say I have no idea what's
going on here maybe there's something
important here but I can't interpret it
um so and they say okay so NK is natural
killer cytotoxic T cells these are T
cells that kill your own cells also also
sort of
colloquially called killer T cells yep
both phenotypically resembling cytokine
driven killer cells now what they're
saying is
inflammation and actually people who
listen to the uh the Umberto maduri
polymeric podcast which I highly
recommend we'll maybe come back to it
later uh we'll remember a discussion
that we had in there about the fact that
inflammation is part of the body the
body's adaptive response to disease and
that it gets away from us for various
reasons and that's when it's
pathological it's not that inflammation
is inherently bad it's part of the
immune response but then it can get away
from you which is where things become
serious but what they say
is that you've got cytokine you've got
these uh cytotoxic T cells natural
killer cells both phenotypically
resembling cytokine driven killer cells
so what they're describing is they are
peering into the process of
so-called vaccine-induced myocarditis
and they are finding the body reacting
as if it is fending off an infection in
the heart a exactly as I proposed
in addition patients displaying
signatures of inflammatory and
pro-fibric ccr2 and cd163 plus monocytes
coupled with elevated serum soluble
cd163 that may be linked to late
gadolinium enhancement or cardiac on
cardiac MRI so they're talking about
something that they're seeing uh you
know they're looking into these hearts
with magnetic resonance imaging and
they're seeing pathologies that are
grossly evidence these are not molecular
level pathologies but they're seeing
them
a lot of specifics here that are going
to be inside baseball
um even even for us with regard to uh
you know what what are the indicators
that are useful since by and large you
cannot detect damage directly so what
we're seeing here is a lot of proxies
for damage measured in a lot of
different ways a lot of products
different proxies a lot of different
measurements but they say so that last
sentence we go back to the beginning of
it in addition patients displayed
signatures of inflammatory and
pro-fibric CCR uh Pro fibrotic which
means this is basically Scar Tissue
formation that's what that means and so
uh what we're talking about is not okay
this patient had a transient
inflammation of the heart which went
away and thank goodness they got away
with it now they can go back to life the
point is they lost capacity in the heart
you know this is not proven but what
they're saying is we see a pathology
that is consistent with a heart damaged
by natural killer cells and cytotoxic T
cells in which scarring is the best
repair that can be made so that heart is
now damaged for life it now scars in the
best case and this person is now
vulnerable to things like arrhythmias
they are less capable than they once
were and this is a potentially
life-shortening pathology right and so
let me I know we're not done with the
abstract yet you're in the middle here
still but
um you mentioned
you know this is therefore not transient
so then have they been getting away with
calling uh the myocarditis and the
pericarditis transient in so many cases
uh in part and some of this will no
doubt be intentional but much of it will
probably be um utterly unintentional
because doctors like everyone in any
field will often conflate the underlying
thing with the thing that they are
measuring and imagine that they are the
same if what you are measuring is uh
inflammation in its acute phase that
acute inflammation will indeed be
transient and so then you take that that
conclusion out into the world and say ah
yes damage wow are bad but it's it's
over and done with after a while because
we can't see it anymore can we so the
thing that is being measured is indeed
transient but there was never any reason
to conclude therefore that the damage
that that inflammation was indicating
would be transient as well right so it's
a little bit like if you had a
building collapse and you detected it by
the dust that was kicked up the dust
might clear but it doesn't put the
building back up right so anyway they're
using proxies which is frankly what you
just simply analogy what you have to do
with all of this stuff right um because
we're dealing with
mechanisms inside a living person and
it's it's it's difficult to assess right
but I mean I think I also I just want to
point to the media that grabbed onto
this like it's transient it's fine
um the it's fine thing was their
conclusion
based on a misunderstanding in part
because of the misunderstanding of the
people actually doing the research of
what what transient is a reference to
transient is not a reference to the
damage transient is a reference to the
particular thing that was measured as an
indicator of the damage and so whenever
you see any of these conclusions being
trotted out in the media you have to you
have to wonder what actually are you
talking about right like transient in
this case
um is true and and people will you know
go to their grave saying no but it's
transient it's like yes but the thing
that's transient isn't anything worth
talking about actually that the only
reason we're talking about that is
because that was what was measurable and
you know the map is not the territory at
some level remember the Spin Doctors
the the group the 1990s yeah band yeah
great album yeah um
the Spin Doctors were named after a
phenomenon that was very real called
spin doctor Spin Doctors were people who
went I believe to presidential debates
and maybe other things and they were
there in the room ready they were
listening to the debate and if their
candidate the one they had been hired to
protect screwed up they would
immediately Lodge in the the room of
people who were trying to figure out how
they were going to report the story they
would Lodge the interpretation that
minimized the damage or flipped it into
a win or whatever now the idea is okay
how are we going to take the dire fact
of these radically novel transfection
agents producing heart damage how are we
going to get the The Blue Team faithful
to all you know look down their noses at
people who are concerned and say
um you're obviously a right-wing nut job
everyone knows the myocarditis is you
know and then transient is going to be
the way they're going to spin this very
devastating indictment of that
technology
into something that no reasonable person
could worry about that's what they did
all right so let's just uh finish this
out here together our results
demonstrate up regulation of
inflammatory cytokines and corresponding
lymphocytes with tissue
tissue damaging capabilities suggesting
a cytokine dependent pathology which may
further be accompanied by myeloid cell
Associated cardiac fibrosis what they
are saying is what we see is a reaction
consistent with the body damaging its
own heart
why would it do that because it's
programmed to fend off viruses if they
get in there as bad as heart damage is
an infected heart is worse so that's
what they see is a pattern consistent
with that that results then in
cell-associated cardiac fibrosis that is
to say scarring which is the best case
it's bad but it's the best case
these findings likely rule out some
previously proposed mechanisms of our of
mRNA vaccine Associated myo
myopericarditis and Point new ones with
relevance to vaccine development and
clinical care so what that means is the
offit mechanism that he proposed last
week I don't know if he proposed it
before that is not consistent with the
findings that they made and what is
consistent they say that this is a new
uh proposal or a new set of observations
but the point is you ought to notice
that that new set of observations is
consistent with a hypothesis that we put
together
on camera on Dark Horse
now I do want to say
I say my hypothesis
I do not mean this is my hypothesis
alone and in fact I went back to the
original
um this is important where you're about
to go and this takes us far from this
paper can I just share a couple of
excerpts from the end of the paper first
because because we're probably not going
to come right back to this paper uh the
very end of the discussion of the paper
on the basis of our findings
longitudinal clinical monitoring of
vaccine Associated myopericarditis
patients may be warranted to assess
potential Persistence of cardiac
abnormalities
yes
than in the same paragraph yeah and may
be warranted is uh is then in the same
paragraph future studies building on the
translational relevance of our work will
be important important to further
optimize the excellent safety profile of
mRNA vaccines among specific demographic
subgroups amen amen right now they do
you know specific demographic subgroups
you know it is becoming acceptable and
they it will be required soon to reflect
back and say yes maybe we shouldn't have
been vaccinating the young men after all
are bad right like that is becoming the
thing that is now not only acceptable
but necessary and this uh specific
demographic subgroups is the nod to that
future uh Orthodoxy but will will we
ever get to a legitimate Orthodoxy in
which there is widespread understanding
that as you are saying and this is where
I'm going to just hand it right back to
you actually this these these were not
ready these were not ready they couldn't
have possibly been ready this platform
is not ready and no one should have
gotten it yeah nowhere near ready right
but I mean look
I don't want to say anything negative
about these authors my guess is these
authors faced a problem they did good
work it successfully advances the ball
in terms of how much we know this now
goes out of the realm of hypothesis we
now have a mechanism that appears is now
the presumptive mechanism right we know
what it is and we now know what it
implies and frankly that's hugely
important but the fact that they have to
riddle this piece of excellent work with
uh you know various incantations
uh designed to placate various powerful
Gods is absurd and that last one
probably wouldn't have gotten published
in science Immunology but for those nods
to the Orthodoxy right and the Orthodoxy
is
I don't like the term evil but if you're
gonna take a radical dangerous
technology like this and you're going to
claim that it's only really bad for
certain demographics young healthy men
like that's not a certain demographic
and what's more of the paper that we
talked about either last week or the
week before that found the one in 35 uh
vaccinated people had elevated troponin
levels it was actually women who were
more commonly uh showing this sign so
hey we don't know how extensive the
damage is and these aren't limited
subgroups healthy young men is a you
know is that a demographic that half the
population well that's
you can talk about demographic groups
and know that there are some you know
who they are intending to keep in the
line of fire for these and future mRNA
vaccines is older and immune compromised
people and people other who otherwise
have comorbidities that put the
particular risk for whatever the
pathogen is that we're talking about oh
no I'm sorry I'm pushing back because
the very sentence I think it was the
same sentence they say optimize the
excellent safety profile
what in God's name does that mean these
things I mean that's why that's why I
read it but I don't think um you know
specific demographic subgroups is a
legitimate way to understand uh
populations you know we we know we were
talking about as were some other people
the need to risk stratify uh both our
understanding of covid and our
understanding of the MRNA vaccines
um as they were being trotted out and
almost no one was doing it and that was
part of why you got you know parents
living you know scared parents living in
scared fear until they could get their
tiny children vaccinated uh with uh
so-called vaccines that were much more
risk of doing damage to their children
than the virus ever would right risk
stratification is a massively important
thing that we need to be talking about
stratification is great but when you
have a novel technology that is a threat
to a huge fraction of the population and
then you minimize it by talking about
demographic groups instead of saying
actually we don't know how big a threat
this is and we don't know if we're
noticing it in young healthy people
because it gets obscured by the
pathologies that older unhealthy people
tend to have anyway way so the point is
this it they're just way ahead of what
we understand and they're using language
to minimize it and that's not cool that
said again the authors did excellent
work and they got it into a high profile
top-tier publication and they may have
these are compromises they may have had
to do and I don't judge them for that
okay
back to the other point I keep saying my
hypothesis
I do not mean it is my hypothesis alone
and I went back to the initial
presentation of it on Dark Horse from
February of 22 and in fact in that
initial presentation what I say is that
I was working this out and I presented
it to some people privately and they
told me that they had heard a related
hypothesis or maybe the same hypothesis
deployed by others and I went and looked
and I found Peter McCullough had alluded
to such a thing I now know Mark girardo
has alluded to such a thing I mean in
fact his whole bolus Theory with which I
have one significant disagreement but
his bolus theory is predicated on the
same idea I ran into a new one this week
David Wakefield of all people had
described a similar magnet so why am I
focused on this being my hypothesis if
it wasn't mine alone
I want to make this clear to people one
the system
requires us to track where ideas come
from and how well they stand up to test
now when I say it's mine what I mean is
I didn't get it from anybody else okay I
put this together based on what I
understood
that means if it turns out to be borne
out by empirical tests as it now has
that that tells you something about how
good my model is not perfect maybe I
could have been more precise I certainly
could have been earlier and I wish I had
but nonetheless the point is one if the
system is supposed to work people who
have predictive power have to have their
credibility elevated now
you and I so if the system does this
badly if you elevate Thieves for example
then you get the inverse effect where
people who aren't responsible for a
particular thing get credit and they
have their credibility elevated the
system to evolve in the right direction
you have to be able to track who was
capable of seeing something coming
making a valid prediction and then
having that prediction borne out but the
other thing is you and I have endured
um
shocking indictments of our credibility
and effectively attacks on whether or
not we belonged in a conversation about
covid and its treatment and this has
gone on for a very long time and it's
been in some very close quarters we have
been ruthlessly attacked by Sam Harris
of course who has indicted our
credibility and he said he's not the guy
to do any of this analysis because he
doesn't know what's going on but clearly
we don't either now my point would be
this doesn't have to be my hypothesis
alone but if you can see that I'm
capable of taking the facts of this and
somehow being way ahead of the folks at
Pfizer who apparently still can't
explain why myocarditis has anything to
do with their damn shot right and ahead
of Paul offit who is blaming uh
molecular mimicry of heart proteins and
all of that if you can see that then you
know that somehow
this is legitimate analysis that is
leading you to see things well ahead
even the authors of this paper call
their observations new they say this
suggests a new pathology well it's not
it was predicted by by hypothesis
outside of any laboratory setting and
that is an important that is an
important consideration
aim a model that is capable of
predicting results in the lab is a
powerful model and so all I'm saying is
somewhere we have to have the tables
turned on all of the attacks that were
made on our credibility because the fact
is we have been right we didn't guess
where we were wrong we corrected it and
that is what you want in in people who
are analyzing situations on which our
health depends
that's right
um you know we've we've spent we've
dipped in and out of sort of philosophy
of science and epistemology that is how
it is that we make claims of truth I
want basis do we make claims of Truth
uh many times on Dark Horse and and
elsewhere but it warrants
um a revisit here because it's part it's
part of what you're doing it's part of
what is implied by what you're talking
about here and uh part of one way one of
many ways to categorize science types of
science ways of doing science
um you know the kinds of things that
scientists engage in is empirical versus
theoretical work
right and empirical work is that which
takes a hypothesis and usually
hopefully it is the researcher who is
doing the empirical work who is himself
or herself generated the hypothesis or
hypotheses that they are testing
um and uh
describes and executes an experimental
test or an observational test of said
hypothesis and generates data actual
numbers actual measurements and then is
the analysis on those data and depending
on the type of work of statistical
analysis uh perhaps or some other
analysis and generates a result
that is empirical work in which there is
something that has actually been
measured
the generation of hypothesis
or
the in including the generation of
hypothesis
where you do not have any intention of
nor do you have the background too
because you do not have the familiarity
with the equipment with the various
molecules you might be measuring
um in a field
where you can look at what is out there
and say
I think it's this this is this is the
prediction that I make given what we can
see right now and here's what would have
to be true if so that is theoretical
work because it does not include any
measurement you do not you do not have
to be out there measuring and analyzing
data
in order to be doing theoretical work
both are necessary both theoretical work
and empirical work are necessary to do
science
for a variety of reasons
from something like the mid 20th century
on
and you know maybe to some degree from
time immemorial but empirical work has
been privileged has in in in big science
in academic science
this is in part because it leaves a
clear Trace
and in part because it is expensive to
do and expensive is a good thing for the
purposes of academic science because
expensive science means big grants means
lots of overhead to the universities
it's a favored thing it is it is a it it
is the thing that the administrations of
universities who house scientists want
they want scientists to do expensive
science not inexpensive science speaks
expensive science forces the scientists
to spend more of their time being grits
Getters and Grant administrators as
opposed to actually doing science
whereas
Theory and you know the term
theoretician is confusing with regard to
you know our contention that you know
it's not a theory until it's past you
know many many many
basically tests right it's a hypothesis
to start but we call these theoreticians
versus empiricists
theoreticians largely don't need big
grants to do their work and so this is
one of several reasons that theoretical
work has been pushed to the Wayside in
modern scientific circles and as a
result you have a number of people who
have degrees in science who have the
accreditments of science who appear to
be doing science who are who the media
go to when they need something sciency
to be said to them
who might not recognize a hypothesis
with a testable prediction if it hit
them in the head and that means that
what they are doing may be absolutely
necessary but it's a piece of Science
and it's not all of Science and frankly
it's not the hard part of science it's
not the rigorous part of science using
equipment that other people have
generated with molecules that are
signifiers that are proxies for things
that other people have generated is not
actually that hard it's a little bit
like following a recipe and you have to
be good at following a recipe but you
don't have to actually be able to see
the big picture whereas theoreticians
generally do
so
one it's worse than that 4 Theory and
the reason that it's worse than that is
that not only is Theory cheap to do but
Theory eliminates a large fraction of
the experimental work that gets done by
giving you a map of where to look so say
that more so what what you what you mean
there is if you don't have an idea about
what you're doing if you don't have a
map if you don't have a theoretical
understanding of the situation you could
throw the dice and do any number of
almost infinite number of experiments
and most of them will be irrelevant
because all it would have taken was
having a theoretical approach to begin
with so narrow the narrow the subset of
experiments or tests of hypothesis that
you might have done in the first place
yeah that are worth doing and in fact
you can see that right here because
let's say we take Paul offutt's feeble
understanding of the danger of these
things okay it's based on the antigen
that the MRNA
transcript produces
well let's suppose you wanted to make
some other so-called vaccines on the
same platform you got to run a test for
every single one of them in order to
figure out whether they are good or bad
antigens on the other hand if the
theoretical viewpoints is actually no
the platform is fundamentally flawed and
it's not you know Spike protein is bad
but it's not just the spike protein the
lipid nanoparticles are bad but it's not
just the lipid nanoparticles it's
actually the most fundamental element
here the one you can't swap out
well it's the MRNA transcripts that
produce a foreign protein in your cells
which is going to get your cells
targeted and then the pseudo-uridine
stabilization of the mrnas that make
this process a long-term process rather
than a short-term process if your
theoretical understanding leads you to
that the point is you don't need to go
test every antigen that's right it's
already it it's not going to be
productive as soon as you've got a
foreign antigen you know that you're
stepping into the same mechanism now you
might want to run a few tests because it
would tell you something if hey it
doesn't matter what antigen we swap in
as long as it's foreign we see the same
thing that would tell you oh yeah this
model was correct but knowing that this
is from widely disparate antigens right
so the point is
the part of the academic system that has
gone full bore on the idea that the data
is King that uh science is high is uh
data driven right this is a coup and it
is staged against Theory now you can't
doing Theory alone isn't any good you
have to do the empirical tests but
someone does
someone and that's the other thing I
just have to be done the empirical tests
have to be done and I was going to argue
these clinical tests also can't exist
absent the theoretical work in the in
the first place and those can be done by
the same people they can be now there's
a risk when they are done by the same
people and the risk is that the perverse
incentives cause us to see a false
scientific picture because people who
have a dog in the fight may run a test
that they may throw away the tests that
falsify and they may publish the tests
that validate yeah well but but I mean
just you know from from our particular
experience you didn't do that much
empirical work right um I I did and it
was not in this scope at all uh and both
of us 100 generated our own hypothesis
we were acting as both um you know
theoretical theoreticians and
empiricists um for the the field work
that we did uh and what we haven't
spelled out here explicitly is when it
is you who are going to then be doing
the empirical work it is even more
necessary than under other circumstances
that you look in advance to try to find
the complete solution set of possible
hypotheses such and you know will you
still have one that you favor Perhaps
Perhaps and that is what the scientific
process is supposed to help eradicate
your you know the individuals who are
doing the science will have bias and you
cannot get rid of human bias but the
scientific method is one road to
minimizing it you may still have a
favorite hypotheses but if you have many
all of which might explain a pattern
that you have observed then you are less
likely to say ah um you know as you
falsify one after another of your you
know treasured hypotheses well that's
just the way it goes I'm out here to try
to figure out what is true as opposed to
validate what I think is true even as I
continue to see evidence that I was
wrong that's all well and good in places
where you don't have
huge financial incentives you know if
you're studying frogs or bats or
whatever you can teach people that they
have to have scientific integrity and it
might work
it doesn't work when you come close to
the money that was that's what I learned
from the the telomere debacle it was the
closer you get to the money the more
Ruthless People become the more eager
they are to steal the more
clever they are at lying to themselves
which brings me to the next Point here
what you have now is what you might call
a paradox
let's take
Sam Harris's confused view because I
think in some ways he speaks well for
The Blue Team myopia
what Sam Harris says is I acknowledge
that the institutions are compromised in
an unacceptable way
but you're far better off
with the institutions than out in the
wild West trying to do your own research
or whatever he wants to demonize
now here's what you now know
that's not true
you watched if you saw that clip which
you can check out uh uh Jimmy Dore and I
spoke about the clip of the Pfizer execs
in Australia being questioned where they
couldn't give any explanation at all of
how myocarditis might arise from their
shots we can give a perfectly coherent
One turns out laboratory work Bears it
out
they can't give any answer they can't
say it might be one of four things and
lay them out even in you know who are
these people so
what you now know
is that various people right you have
um Peter McCullough Mark Gerardo you
have us
all spotted this issue David Wakefield
that ought to make you think
um
you have all of these folks who spotted
that the the brochure if you will of
these vaccines what we were told about
how they were supposed to work predicts
this pathology if you simply extrapolate
from it properly Zach do you want to put
up that Pfizer diagram of how they're
their so-called vaccine works
all right here is Pfizer's own cartoon
of how the vaccine works and I borrowed
this from a tweet of Mark curardos and
this is how do we know is there a date
on this what is this from I don't know
and I don't think it matters okay
as far as you know they still vouch for
this this is still yeah and I don't
think there's anything wrong with their
diagram but the point is what it is is a
cell that has picked up lipid
nanoparticle coded mrnas transcribed to
foreign protein and exported it to its
surface that's all you need to know if
you understand how immune the immune
system works in order to spot that it is
at least a question whether or not this
is going to trigger your own system to
attack your cells and then that will
lead you to the obvious question of well
which cells are going to do the
transcribing
well they told us those the cells that
we're going to do the transcribing were
going to be in your deltoid
as soon as you know that that's not true
you have a four alarm fire
so this was all deducible
why is it that the academy didn't deduce
it why is it that the obviously
excellent scientists who were capable of
sorting out this mechanism and finding
the empirical evidence that it exists
why is it that they haven't been
thinking this was a likely explanation
all along or if they were thinking it
why they didn't lay it out as a
pre-existing hypothesis here
so I mean you know the answer well
you've already said why it's the money
it's the money
but more in part and many different uh
both money scales and temporal scales so
now I want to flip this question on its
head and I want to give you the scariest
observation of all that comes out of
everything we saw drank of it
it was very easy to out think the
experts
doesn't mean it was easy to do out
thinking experts is tough but they were
thinking so feebly
that it was very easy to outpace them it
was very easy to get ahead and get ahead
doesn't mean be more compelling get
ahead means be more predictive see
things coming ahead of time that the
experts claim not to have known were
coming now we don't know if they were
lying or they're too dumb to get it but
it doesn't matter the lesson here is one
that actually you will have heard hinted
at many times on Dark Horse
you may remember a conversation that I
had with Steve Patterson in which Steve
Patterson and I had both come up with
the idea that we were living in a dark
age Steve Patterson puts the beginning
of that Dark Age earlier than I do but
it doesn't much matter the idea that
this vibrant technological sphere in
which we live is actually
a cryptic Dark Age
in which our scientific tools are
artificially feeble because our belief
structure is interfering with their use
that's where we are and the evidence
that that's where we are is now in plain
sight
you have a novel technological mechanism
being deployed massively across the
globe that was foreseeably going to do
damage to all your tissues including
your heart that was foreseeable based on
what was understood and the people who
were supposed to do the foreseeing
couldn't see it
what do you have you have dissidents on
the outside saying here's a problem it's
evident that it will be real why are we
not looking at it and the answer is oh
well those are quacks those are quacks
you can just I mean look at their
Wikipedia Pages they're quacks these
aren't people you'd listen to you've got
to listen to the institutions because as
frustratingly flawed as they may be they
are the gold standard no they are not
they're not Quacks
well they are and they're not they are
the official quacks and the actual
quacks don't quack at all some of them
um so the I got very confusing it did
get confused well that's the way with
ducks they're uh confusing Clan they are
confusing at confusing clade but anyway
point being what I learned in graduate
school
is that a stuck field
is easy to beat doesn't mean it's easy
to get credit doesn't mean it's easy to
get heard but if you just simply want to
understand the world Better Than People
in a stuck field all you've got to do is
free yourself from obligations to their
sacred principles right
that works you've now seen it happen
with covid where people who just simply
were not part of that system either
freed themselves from it or weren't part
of it in the first place we're able to
figure out what was coming ahead of
everybody else that ought to terrify you
because what that says is that all of
those fields in which the so-called
experts were minted are broken they are
incapable of protecting your health and
that includes medicine includes includes
virology it includes vaccinology it
includes the entire regulatory apparatus
these things are broken and I would
claim Beyond repair
that's not a good thing but nonetheless
the evidence is right there so
that's where we are and it does suggest
that this dark age is having
implications in ways that are not
abstract and theoretical this isn't some
you know discussion to have in your
Speakeasy this is actually a material
emergency in which we have vaccinated a
good fraction of the people on planet
Earth with something that never should
have been injected into them and we did
so even though there were foreseeable
harms that some of us tried to to raise
the alarm about and instead of listening
to those people and saying hey that's a
good point maybe we ought to study that
we were demonized and belittled and okay
that didn't work but it could have it
worked better than it should have so
that's a that's a pretty dire picture
but it is now a picture supported by the
evidence right we don't have to we don't
have to wonder whether or not Peter
McCullough is a a quack who was once
Well published in this field but now
he's become a a compromised marginal
thinker nope he was right his colleagues
who didn't see this and injected who
knows how many people they were wrong
that's where we are
yep that is where we are
um and
I don't know
if it will be recognized
well it has to be and I I do have the
feeling in the last
week
that
the again we've been we've been talking
about this issue of your own
self-producing foreign proteins and
triggering an autoimmune response that
damages your own heart we've been
talking about that since February of 22.
the
right now August of 23
that idea is finally lodging in enough
Minds in enough public discussion
something about that off it piece caused
this now to be a question because maybe
presenting that hypothesis in isolation
doesn't work but presenting it as a
competing everybody's heard of Spike
protein everybody knows that they're
supposed to fear it and then when Paul
offut overplayed his hand and tried to
blame the spike protein for everything
it made it possible to say here's why as
good as that sounds as much as that
sounds like an admission of what they
did wrong it's actually the opposite
that that allowed this to break into
public I don't know that the genie goes
back in the bottle on this one I think
they may have screwed this up now in the
same way that they screwed up lab leak
and I think we may finally be able to
have this discussion uh in a in a sober
way
right
Genies are going back in bottles all the
time not by actually stuffing Genies
back in bottles but by uh
it's like the the genie metaphor
equivalent of dilution being the
solution to pollution you can kind of
like there's so many Genies out there
and there's so many misdirections there
are so many things that you can draw
people's attention to over there you
know will it be another new virus will
it be another new war will it be another
visit from Aliens well like there's
there's a lot of places that distract
people and then coming back to this like
oh God covet again
must we well I'll tell you I'll tell you
how we're gonna know I think
I think oh I think we'll know I just uh
have little faith that it will actually
happen because I think we are up against
something that is
um not willing to lose well I don't care
I mean it lost lab leak
it lost lab leak and is now losing
control of this one and
it is gonna it is gonna have to face up
to this because if it tries to load
other things into that mRNA platform and
it has a repeat on myocarditis and
pericarditis which is effectively
inevitable then people are going to know
they're gonna know what they're looking
for
so here's here's how I think we will
know whether or not this one has finally
crossed a threshold where they can't uh
they can't re-obscure it
there are many people who have played
a net positive role on covet some of
whom I like very much personally and in
terms of their professional contribution
but who have had what I would call a
misplaced caution
over uh what to do about covet and their
caution has caused them to stop short of
saying things like what Peter McCullough
has said which is there needs to be an
immediate halt to this vaccination
campaign it should stop completely right
others have said well maybe we should
limit it and stop injecting it into
people who are comparatively
unthreatened by covid because they're
young and healthy Etc maybe we just
limit it to people who are old or in
feebled or both
and that has never been right it never
made any sense because these
inoculations are just for starters
not only are they structured in a way
that is
should be presumed to cause this
pathology as soon as you know they don't
stay in the deltoid is there a way to
keep them out of your heart nope it's
not there therefore that's a risk but
they are also
a double violation of Nuremberg
Nuremberg the words that they were
deployed yes it's not the technology
itself but the fact that it was injected
into people who were led to believe that
these things were safe and effective
means that those people were not
informed so they couldn't engage in
informed consent because they were not
informed and in fact there was a
systematic campaign designed to prevent
them from becoming informed and then
they were coerced and the fact is both
of those these things are forbidden
informed consent has to not be coerced
and it has to be correctly informed not
misinformed so you have a double
violation of Nuremberg and my point
would be there's no
there's no principle by which Nuremberg
should ever be violated the fact that we
did violate it and now we have a huge
population of people that can tell us
something new about the pathologies and
who they afflict most is irrelevant you
don't get to inject some huge fraction
of the population and then figure out
what the dangers are and then you know
back off your vaccination campaign and
exclude some people from it these things
were not properly tested they sped them
right past all of the things that would
have told us that this was true either
in animals or told us this was true in a
small number of unfortunate people who
were part of a clinical trial and so
what I want to know is when those folks
are going to recognize that what's on
the table what we now know about the the
pathologies emerging from this are
serious they are well supported by
evidence
they are not rare and that that means
that nobody should be injected with
these things not another one and that
was true from the beginning now it's
very very clear it's true so I'm waiting
to see all of those folks who have been
advocating for a voluntary process of
getting vaccinated with this stuff
or a limited process where we vaccinate
the vulnerable or whatever it is none of
those things make any sense in light of
what we now know and I am expecting that
those people in that group with
Integrity which is a great many are
going to have to reconcile themselves to
the idea that
caution about backing off the vaccine
program is not where it should be the
caution should have been in deploying it
and halting it should be something we do
instantaneously now now that we know
what we know and we should have done it
all along
I agree obviously that we should have
done it all along
um I do Wonder uh to what extent
um
politics affects even the good people in
a non-egregious way such that
um some people who have been advocating
for you know not giving these products
to the young and healthy and and paying
specifically attention to the risk
stratification of both the disease and
the vaccine
um can't could begin to be heard just as
we could begin to be heard
more effectively by coming at it in
stages
and that that truth is not inherently
nefarious
I agree all I'm saying is
I don't think that that was ever
what was Unknown about these
inoculations
was substantial enough that objection to
the entire process was correct from the
beginning I do understand that people
you know as the authors of this paper
are caught in a bind that many of the
high integrity folks have been caught in
in a bind there's lots of stuff that you
and I know excuse me that you and I know
that we don't say sure right and that
that should be true for all intelligent
people who are speaking publicly about
things uh for which the majority of
people have been sold a bunch of lies
right but that that's my point is
whatever process LED people to say less
than they knew or to understand less
than they should have
that's gone at this point any reasonable
person looking at the evidence who has
Integrity should be on the side of wait
a minute what did we do
this should never have happened and if
it should never have happened no part of
it should be continuing period the end
so that is what I am hoping for and that
is what I am expecting uh if those folks
are up to the challenge and it's not
going to be easy because of course as we
started this discussion within the
academy there is a religion that
requires you to mumble the the right
kinds of words in order not to be viewed
as a heretic so okay the question is can
you now join the Heretics long enough
for what should have happened long ago
to happen now
I really hope that it it does
indeed
did you want to talk about the paper in
the strangely named Journal vaccine X
yes um
so you I I thought you wanted to talk
about that as part of this um as part of
this uh just I'll set it up slightly
although I don't know much
um you can show my screen if you want
um this is uh
you you mentioned this paper existed its
title is relapsing myocarditis following
initial recovery of post covid-19
vaccination and two adolescent males
case reports so the paper is as that
title suggests two case reports of um
relapsing recurring my architis in a 15
and a 16 year old male after
no vaccination but just a word first
about the journal what a strange name
for a journal it turns out
um that so it's elsevier which is the
you know the most major of the
publishing of the academic publishing
outfits the most predatory I think as
well maybe that goes along with uh being
major it likes to claim that it was
Galileo's publisher that claim does not
stand up to scrutiny uh it's really
they've used the name of Galileo's
publisher but anyway they like to claim
that it's that old and important yeah so
I mean they publish a huge number of the
influential scientific journals also
um I believe correct me if I'm wrong
maybe you won't know a number of
textbooks I I believe they're also
textbook Publishers as well which of
course is totally separate well not
totally separate is a um a different way
of uh getting money out of people who
shouldn't have money extracted from them
in that rate which is to say
undergraduates mostly and you know
medical medical students
um anyway vaccine X
um
is basically the paid for play the
pay-to-play version of the journal
vaccine vaccine is elsevier's uh premium
peer-reviewed journal and vaccine X is a
pay-to-play journal where for two
thousand dollars you can get your paper
in vaccine X so uh I don't think there's
anything wrong with it but I think we
should separate the term
pay to play which I think is a good term
for corruption for pay to publish in
which you have a journal in which there
are editors presumably yeah there yes
and the fact the fact is this is not a
peer-reviewed journal it looks like one
but it is not and that scheme is not
uncommon and there's nothing inherently
wrong with something in such a thing and
I would also point out if you well
um
peer review is of course completely
broken yep
um the idea that you need resources in
order to publish on top of a system in
which you basically need resources in
order to do any research that is going
to be recommended or recognized by an
academic institution uh just further
makes science one you know an elite
process that is not open to people who
actually know how to who only know how
to think but don't also already have
Resources with which to publicize what
they want with which to actually do what
they want to do or publicize what they
want to do yeah I did not I did imply
but I did not mean to imply there's
nothing wrong with the idea of a pay to
publish Journal there is nothing
inherently wrong with the work in a pay
to publish Journey absolutely
um I think pay to published journals are
a Despicable and predatory outgrowth of
a very broken and and corrupt system but
the fact that something shows up and one
doesn't count for it or against it it's
effectively like a different version of
the archive where you have unpublished
unreviewed work that is available it
just gives the veneer of legitimacy that
comes from a journal that looks you
can't tell just by looking at that page
that this is uh pay to publish rather
than peer review
and I believe there are hybrids but
nonetheless never mind any of that what
you have here is a paper
and you know you could say well it's a
very small study because it only
involves two people but what it really
is is two case reports it says so uh of
adolescent males who got myocarditis
following a
administration of these coveted
so-called vaccines
and what it reports is
something you want to read or should I
just summarize it yeah you can what they
report is that even though
these cases had appeared to clear up
that effectively they've got relapses
and those relapses appear to be about uh
I believe it says that they show new
lesions upon investigating the hearts of
these young people yeah this CMR which I
can't remember what that stands for
um showed new focal areas of edema in
the first case report and stable lesions
in the second one they reached full
recovery with normalization of cardiac
enzymes after a few days so full
recovery being the measure of the
cardiac enzymes yeah only
um
okay so anyway the reason that we raised
this is because again it puts the lie
and yes it's two cases but it suggests
I'm sorry CMR that's cardiac magnetic
resonance scanning so these are uh it's
MRI space it's MRIs of the heart yep
the
the problem here is that we have been
told again and again that we are
terrible people for casting doubt on
these marvelous inoculants which they
call vaccines and that the fact that
myocarditis well of course I'm sure it
may happen but it's extremely rare and
it clears up and so it's not a big deal
and so who are we to worry and the
answer is
you don't know anything I'm not I'm not
sure I would have predicted that it
would clear up and recur but the idea
that people who've gotten a clean bill
of health after having myocarditis which
no cardiologist would tell you is a
minor condition
or no good cardiologist anyway
um the fact that these relapses occur is
extremely concerning why are they
occurring is it an ongoing pathology
even though the heart has cleared these
mrnas or the mrnas that have been hyper
stabilized with these pseudo-uridines
migrating around that is not obvious and
in any case the idea that people who had
effectively no risk from covid in the
first place were inoculated with
something that had this potential and
that then the concerns of other people
who might think well maybe I shouldn't
get one because myocarditis doesn't
sound like something I want we're told
well if you do get it and that's going
to be very unlikely which it isn't but
if you do get it it's likely to be
transient and you'll you'll go on your
way no no big deal and the answer is no
how many times we have to say it we're
talking about hearts and we're talking
about heart damage and the fact is heart
damage doesn't repair you get a scar and
a scar means you have a lesser heart
that's a heart that can do less it's
less efficient it's less capable of
enduring insult in the future this is
not a minor issue at all and the fact
that
these Maniacs decided to inject people
who stood to gain effectively nothing
from it in spite of the fact that the
inoculations didn't prevent transmission
which still wouldn't have Justified
giving them to people who stood to gain
no benefit personally but
they don't block transmission it didn't
control the disease so that we harmed
these people for no reason whatsoever
and the harm is one that is going to
adjust how long many of these people
live and what they can do during that
lifetime is there anything you know more
precious that you could Rob someone of
this is this is robbing them of their
own physiologically generated Freedom
the capacity to live a life that you
don't have to worry that your heart was
damaged by some
stupid experiment that somebody ran on
you in
2021 yeah now we're just going to take a
youthful figure away from you that's all
that's all that's all and you know make
you potentially a lifelong uh
consumer for a Pharmaceuticals to deal
with the heart problems that they've
caused and you know mind you also it's
been weeks maybe months since we talked
about it but the fact that these things
were seemed to have been driven to be
injected into young people and put on
the childhood schedule for cynical
reasons of creating legal immunity for
the shots that were injected into adults
this is just this is disgusting and I
don't know how many different lines of
evidence
you need
but it seems really unambiguous that as
I've said many times
something has become completely
indifferent to the suffering and death
of other people's children
and anytime you're dealing with
something that's that cold you really
have to wonder about anything connected
to it and it is obviously riddled
through our our governmental regulatory
structure our universities our journals
it's uh censoring people on social media
it is
disparaging them on Wikipedia I mean
it's a it's a dire emergency of
criminality that has become so normal
that we barely notice it
that's right
um
there are a number of other things
what we wanted to talk about today but
I'm wondering if we should uh just skip
ahead and talk about bumblebees
about bumblebees
um all right and save save save the rest
for next week
fair enough
um there's some new cool research other
than what you have just revealed to us
this week that has uh no political
ramifications at all I think we'll find
something
I don't think we need to okay it's about
social learning and bumblebees so
I'm an operans which are the ants bees
and wasps as you know uh are often
highly social there are some solitary uh
species of hymenopterans uh and that
sociality is driven in large part by the
use sociality that is Downstream of
their unusual genetics their
haplodiploid uh which uh in means that
all of the females are diploid just like
we are we have two copies of all of our
chromosomes but the males are haploid
they only have one copy and that has all
sorts of fascinating effects including
that for instance full sisters or three
quarters related to one another and
they're only half related to their
mothers and so
um so can selection Theory suggests
there are more likely to be interested
in the production of more sisters than
they are in reproducing on their own
which I'll just add is why the stinging
bees the uh stinging apparatus is
actually the ovipositor it's the egg
layer that has been modified into a
weapon because they don't need it as an
egg layer because they're better off
facilitating the reproduction of their
mother with full siblings
than they are of retaining the capacity
to reproduce themselves right
um now that you know that logic only
holds for full siblings for half
siblings they're a little bit less
related to their half siblings and they
would be three it's related to their
half siblings then they would be related
to their own
um children and that 3 8 is a
probability whereas they're they'd be
exactly half related to their own kids
um we can I'd I'd be happy to go on
endlessly apologetics of haploid
diploidy and other time as I used to
with my students but this is not the
place
um although one of the other interesting
uh effects of the haploidiploid system
in hymenopterans again ants bees and
wasps is that males don't have sons
males only have daughters and sons
therefore males also don't have fathers
they only have um they only have mothers
so all of that is is which makes for a
kind of a fraught relationship
yeah with whom between these fatherless
sons and their mothers who are wrongly
described as Queens but are really
slaves of the colony anyway it's not
fraud at all they're 100 related to
their moms right which
could be rough I don't know no no not
helpful
um so it's been long assumed that the
behaviors of the social insects were
innate genetic right not socially
learned but new research suggests uh
slightly otherwise so uh oh not yet take
my screen off while I scroll to the top
um here okay now you can put my screen
back on
um this published
um I believe this week or at least very
recently in uh plus biology so this is
an Open Access Journal
um high quality Journal bumblebees
acquire alternative puzzle box Solutions
via social learning published by a
number of people out of Queen Mary
University of London
and I will just read first the
introduction and then the abstract and
then we'll talk about a little bit
or the first paragraph or so of the
introduction the diversity of behavior
is observed in some social in in some
insect societies is how par with or
exceeds that of some mammals and
includes the construction of
architecturally complex
climate-controlled nests and the
division of labor between foraging brood
care and Nest defense indeed outside the
human realm their nesting structures are
unparalleled in terms of their
regularity sophistication and their
scale and proportion to body size
there's profound variation in foraging
specializations architectures and social
organizations not just between related
species of social insects but more
intriguingly even within species
while these specializations have
historically been viewed as a limited
set of pre-programmed responses to
external stimuli resulting from
evolutionary trial and error processes
this innate repertoire is supplemented
by a remarkable capacity for learning
that has been recognized for decades the
acquisition of the honeybee dance
language is perhaps the best
characterized example of social learning
described thus far and invertebrate and
as early as 1884 Darwin suggested that
nectar robbing of flowers by bumblebees
could spread socially I did not remember
that that Darwin had suggested this then
they've got
um what they actually did here is uh to
investigate social learning a two-act
action control experimental design is
helpful as this can help exclude
alternative explanations
such designs have been used to great
effect to investigate social learning
and chimpanzees with demonstrators
trained to obtain food from a pan pipes
apparatus in one of two different ways
and observers acquiring their
demonstrators technique
meanwhile without a demonstrator no
chimpanzees acquired either technique
so you seed you seed the culture of
chimpanzees with a way to solve a
problem and The Chimps pick up that way
to solve the problem but they don't
solve the problem at all when you don't
seed it at least in the experiment here
cited
um
meanwhile without a demonstrator more
recently in great tits demonstrators
were trained to open a puzzle box in one
of two possible ways before seating them
back into wild populations
the demonstrator's preferences that's
Birds by the way great tits you knew
that I did yeah
um
the demonstrator's preferences spread
throughout these groups and were
maintained long term even when the
alternative Behavior was discovered and
even though the two variants were
entirely arbitrary
so interesting right two arbitrary
apparently equally good ways to solve a
problem when one or the other is seeded
into a population that's the one that
spreads when when a demonstrator is fed
into a population and it Remains the
consistently preferred one even when
some other non-demonstrated birds uh
stumble across invent whatever learn the
other way of doing things their way
which is supposedly neither better nor
worse although that's going to be really
hard to actually obtain in in a real
world situation
um the the newly discovered way does not
end up winning the day
um
for the present study as you would
expect
my opinion yeah with the big caveat that
the two ways of doing things have to
really be equivalently good and that's
that's a for me that's it being people
you would expect that conservatism yep
uh for the present study we designed two
option puzzle box feeders that formed by
previous work in bumblebee problem
solving which replicated those used to
investigate the spread of arbitrary
behavioral differences in great tip
populations we then developed an open
diffusion protocol that allowed the
spread of box opening through the group
to be recorded and seated colonies of
bumblebees with demonstrators trained to
perform one of the two possible
behavioral variants these novel foraging
techniques were successfully acquired by
untrained bees via social learning
and there's a lot more to say here but
uh as as they allude to there in the
introduction which is uh
odd but they allude to the results in
the discussion there
um
they uh this pref box opening Behavior
spread through colonies seated with a
demonstrator trained to perform one of
the two possible behavioral variants and
The Observers acquired the demonstrated
variant this preference persisted among
observers even when the alternative
technique was discovered
and in control diffusion experiments
that lacked a demonstrator
some bees spontaneously open the puzzle
boxes but for significantly less
proficient than those that learn in the
presence of a demonstrator so much is
what has previously been described
discovered and described in both chimps
and great tits which are in turns mammal
and bird which are known to be you know
have complex brains highly social highly
capable of learning with cultural
transmission of information here we have
a very similar result in bumblebees now
these authors are not going so far as to
call this
um this evidence of culture because
bumblebees die out Bumblebees are
effectively annuals with only the queen
surviving overwintering and so you don't
have the acquisition of this learning
taking place multi-generationally but
you do have it within the season that
that it is happening and thus as the
authors say this is likely to be a
necessary precursor too if not um
sufficient to describe an organism as
having culture
yeah
frankly I find that distinction a little
arbitrary I get why it is they're using
a definition of culture that requires
cross-generational yeah um transmission
yeah and that is a real distinction yep
on the other hand all of the
capabilities here transmitting a
behavioral phenomenon like that across
the population uh I would say
a it raises questions because not all
hymenopterans are annuals
and therefore if the same capacity
existed in something like let's say
thatch ants yeah then you would expect
it to transmit you would expect a colony
to have this capacity and to transmit it
um through generations Generations being
a little bit of a weird term because
you've got presumably a single queen
although there are things that happen
when a queen
dies but anyway all that aside
the reason that you would expect
a group of bees who had learned a
technique from a demonstrator to be
resistant to the acquisition of a new
technique though equally good is that it
wouldn't be equally good because they
would be less proficient at the one they
hadn't practiced precisely and so you
would expect this resistance to doing it
the new way and the real question is how
much better does the new way have to be
than the old way in order to overcome
that conservatism which then becomes a
model for exactly what we have in
Civilization where there's a tendency to
want to do things the way we've done
them which is the right tendency and
then there is sometimes a benefit that
is worth engaging in the changeover cost
well and I think here here is one of the
places where bumblebees being annuals
and humans decidedly not
will make the answer to that question
potentially very different right like if
you've got a colony that has a A month's
months long a lifespan measured in
months rather than a societal lifespan
that could possibly be measured in
Millennia or at least centuries it's a
very different analysis to say okay like
I don't care how many times you managed
to do the thing you're going to be dead
next month and it probably doesn't make
sense for you to learn a totally new
technique when what you're doing is
equally good or even just slightly less
good and I will say actually with regard
to the B work it was like
they had like a turn a red thing
counterclockwise or turn a blue thing
counterclock or clockwise I don't I
don't remember the specifics but there
was a red and a blue tag and red is
right near the edge of what bumblebees
can see very well and so when there is
no demonstrator blue tends to be the
thing that is discovered
they both work equally well and the bees
can see the red but they don't find it
first that said when the demonstrator is
trained on red and blue is discovered in
that Colony red still persists
so that that suggests that sort of like
sensory exploitation is not going on
here right like that oh well we can see
this thing but actually you know George
over here has discovered Georgina over
here is discovered
um you know the thing that we can all
see better so let's go there it's like
you know what we're all going to be dead
soon let's just stick with what we know
well
again this is
there's going to be a threshold of
superiority and in fact I didn't read
the paper so I'm just learning about the
the technique but it does seem to me
that you can actually there you've got a
Continuum of difficulty that you could
deploy that would cause you to find the
Threshold at which the changeover was
worth paying and it would be interesting
whether that changed over that threshold
was at a different place at a different
point in the season yes right precisely
um but anyway that is really interesting
and that does sound like such a fun
experiment doesn't it right there are a
lot of boring things you can do and uh
this is biology graduate school but that
sounds like fun yeah no it it does and
um yeah social learning in in bees
um and just you know reminding us again
uh that we uh imagine ourselves uh the
only ones who are capable of the things
that we do on this planet
uh at our Peril it's it's silly right
you know there are a lot of other ways
to be and many other organisms do things
better than we do and uh and many do
things worse but also there are a lot of
other ways to arrive at similar kinds of
skills and here you have an example in
bumblebees
ways to be a bee I used to be a beam
indeed
all right I think
um that's gotten us to the end of uh our
first
hour or two here we're going to take a
break and come back with a q a that will
only be on Rumble uh and uh and later on
Spotify as well I think are we putting
these on Spotify yeah uh the Q A's
um okay so
um and so you can ask questions uh in
the live q a at uh
darkhorsemmissions.com that's where that
happens we've got a lot of good guest
episodes coming out right now you
mentioned earlier the one uh that just
came out on Saturday with Berto baduri
and Paul Merrick and it's a conversation
which
many people who have watched it have had
a rather profound
experience from it because it talks
about a story an unknown story in fact
we broke it on Dark Horse an unknown
story where pharmaceutical
skullduggery upended a safe therapy
in favor of a new and highly profitable
and not safe
therapy and this It ultimately ended up
having something to do with Kobe but
this started 20 years before so anyway
it's a very interesting story very well
worth engaging and I would encourage you
strongly to to go check it out
excellent
um also please check out Natural
Selections my um my sub stack this week
I posted a piece I read a few years ago
called in the footsteps of those who
came before about walking the yumbo
trails in um in the Andes in the Ecuador
and Andes which uh in the in in the
mountains of South America
the soils are such that when you walk a
path a lot over time it wears it wears
in and the trails some of the trails
that you can now walk in the Andes
specifically in the makapakuna reserve
where we spent time with students
um the walls they're very narrow it's
basically single track uh you wouldn't
want a bike there but it's basically
it's single track you can't go to to
abreast and the walls are sometimes over
the height of a human head often these
are three four foot high walls and
that's not made mostly by moderns these
were made by yumbo people who co-existed
with
um and were actually in some
collaboration with the Inca and existed
before the Inca came to Ecuador so
um it is truly remarkable to know that
you were literally walking in the
footsteps of uh people from a thousand
two thousand years ago and and try to
imagine what their lives were and not
not make simplistic generalizations
about what they must have been because
they were ancients
so that's a substance that's at Natural
Selections this week
um we I would encourage you again to
join our locals we are the Discord is
going to be on there uh soon uh we have
the watch party right now for this and
for our q a uh for for our live streams
and we're going to start doing our
private q a uh only on locals uh
starting uh this month on the last
Sunday of the month
we have
darkhorsestore.org where you can get
some get some stuff sigh up until proven
otherwise dark horse stuff epic Tabby
our epic Tabby has been absent lately
but he'll show up again soon I would
hope
um do you guys even on vacation no it's
August I guess he's like
extended Walkabout now he's fine he's
good he just has been camera shy of late
as has Tesla our our panther cat
um
you can get copies of hunter-gather's
Guide to the 21st century everywhere
books are sold including at darvel's
here on this in the San Juan Islands now
where it's signed and um we forgot to
mention last week that you are
continuing to have excellent
conversations at your patreon and you
had those this last weekend and you will
continue to have those even as we
um move um try to encourage more most
people to move over into locals but your
higher level patrons are still going to
be having conversations with you on the
first Saturday and first Sunday of every
month yep Coalition of the reasonable if
you want to talk about current events
and evolutionary biology is the other
discussion in which we talk about uh
sometimes it involves current events but
it often is focused around evolution
principles and questions anyway they're
both great excellent
and
um both at your patreon and my patreon
and our locals soon you're gonna get
access to our Discord server which is
just a wonderful wonderful group of
people
um engaging in difficult and not so
difficult topics having book clubs
karaoke happy hour lots of great stuff
and every week that we do a q a we start
out with a question from them so that's
another way to
to interact with us
once again we encourage you to check out
our wonderful sponsors this week which
were on cruise and American Hartford
gold and excuse me mud water
and
um
we will have links to those sponsors in
the show notes as well as to the papers
that we talked about this week a
reminder that we are supported by you
our audience
so please consider subscribing to our
channel on Rumble that actually will
help us out
so please consider doing that please
join us on locals
share share whatever you see that you
like share it with your friends and
um
and on YouTube as well we you know we're
demonetized by YouTube over two years
ago and that has not changed and it
looks like it is unlikely to change so
while Goliath does its dirty work on us
we continue to exist but mostly because
of you our audience so we are very very
grateful for your support and um and and
will continue to be so so until we see
you next time be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone